well Iceland was in the years that led
that to the financial crisis like every
country in Europe and the United States
part of this policy transformation where
the financial sector was was deregulated
where the freedom of financial capital
was increased where there was a
different form of regulations and
structures that had prevailed before so
when the financial crisis hit we
suffered in a dramatic way we wear for a
while perhaps exhibit number one of a
failed financial system it was a
profound shock to our country and our
people not just because of the economic
difficulties and the hardship that
followed but also because Iceland is one
of the most democratic and secure
societies in the world and we have
always conducted everything through
peaceful dialogue and discussions but
suddenly we had the riots we had
demonstrations there were fire burnings
in the center of Reykjavik the police
had to defend the Parliament and even
the central bank so it demonstrated that
a collapse of the financial system can
also threaten the democratic
institutions as well as the social
cohesion of one of the most harmonious
and open and free democratic societies
in the world so if a collapse in the
financial system can do such damage and
provide such a threat to a country like
Iceland imagine what a failure in the
financial market can do to countries
where the democratic institutions are
not as strong and solidly based as in my
country but then when we had to
formulate policies how to deal with the
financial crisis we decided in one way
or another to follow a different formula
than from the traditional consensus in
the previous 30
years of how you deal with the financial
crisis we did not save the banks we let
them go bankrupt we introduced currency
controls we devalue the currency we did
not introduce austerity measures of the
scale that had been deemed to be
absolutely necessary in the decades
before and when the failure of one
Atlantic bank in Britain and the
Netherlands led to extraordinary
pressure from all the European
governments that the Icelandic taxpayers
should take responsibility for the
deaths of this one bank in these two
countries I put it to a referendum and I
allowed the Atlantic nations to vote on
it not just once but twice it is I
believe the only occasion where the
Democratic will of the people was deemed
to be more important than the perceived
financial interests of of the markets we
could discuss us was done five years ago
or so whether this was wise and there
were a lot of people not just so called
experts and financial authorities but
also governments all over Europe over
telling us we were absolutely wrong but
this was a crazy path to follow because
it went against the established
orthodoxy but now we know the outcome
six years later that Iceland having been
the exhibit number one of a failed
financial state is now exhibit number
one in Europe of a recovery from a
financial crisis with three to four
percent economic growth with four to
five percent unemployment with many of
our sectors the tourism sector the
energy sector the IT sector the
high-tech sector in fact doing much
better in the last five years than it is
in the five years leading up to the
financial crisis so the end result
spin that this democratic way of dealing
with the financial crisis this
unorthodox way in terms of economic
policy has in fact turned out better and
more solid results than the so-called
expert or official community predicted
so in that sense I think Iceland can
serve as an interesting reference when
other nations discuss and debate what
policies they should follow but above
all what is the relationship between
democracy on one hand and financial
markets on the other there was the
prevailing assumption in the previous
decades that somehow the financial
markets ups you pre but we faced a tough
challenge to decide is the Democratic
will of the people more important than
the forces in the financial markets and
that is in fact the question which many
other nations are not yet answered but
in our case it turned out that allowing
the Democratic will to rule the day was
a better course
you